if there's this term in the poker world
called poker broke where you're still
living okay there's still someone who's
loaned you money or is bankrolling you
and you're still playing in big games
but that only happens if you have the
reputation that goes along with that
bankroll that you're willing to risk so
there's certainly a downside to going
broke but you're not out of the game
it's not like you stopped playing poker
and you go find a job you know somewhere
else so I mean certainly I you know you
need to protect your reputation and you
need to make sure the people at least
still respect your game or you know or
else you really do have to play in such
a way as to make sure that your ruin
factor is sort of zero there are a
couple I think important things about
poker about you know skills that you
learn at the poker table that are very
useful in business you know one thing
that poker trains you to do is I mean
really the definition of poker is trying
to make good decisions you know under
conditions of uncertainty and and
certainly in in business that comes up
all the time you're you're weighing the
chances of certain things happening and
you're trying to maximize your results
and sort of account for certain things
like recessions or you know a downturn
in your market or too much competition
you you constantly have to allocate
resources whether they be you know
manpower or money toward certain things
that you just can't know the future you
know I think another thing and possibly
the most important thing I think that
you bring from the poker table to the
business world is I think a strong sense
of sort of empathy to be a successful
poker player you really have to put
yourself in the position or in the head
of your opponent and I think where that
really comes into play is at the
negotiating table so you have to give
the person you're negotiating with
sort of respect but at the same time
you're trying to probe their weaknesses
figure out exactly you know how strong
their hand is how desperate are they to
sell whatever it is whatever whether
it's a service or or a product to you
and you know really try and negotiate
them down to that price that's not so
good for you that it ends up being a bad
relationship and you and you know but
you certainly don't want to overpay
either and I think the only way that you
actually can consistently you know
negotiation after negotiation after
negotiation and if you're in business
you're just constantly negotiating with
different people you're always trying to
find that right place where you're not
overpaying you're giving them the deal
they need and the only way you can do
that is by thinking about their needs
and what they're bringing to the table
as well as your own you can't just be
sort of negotiating it on one side